my boyfriend died like a couple years
ago and so I have this joke like but you
guys I literally got ghosted and people
in the audience kappa they get so mad
[Music]
people expect me to be funny all the
time
three two one go it's you know if you're
one line of comic did sure someone was
hey tell me a joke you might be able to
pull that off but the overwhelming
majority of us have some sort of
structure where we're telling a
narrative or something of that nature
we're just me and you talking and
introducing it's not conducive to making
you laugh anybody ever says to me oh
you're your community tell me a joke I
just go pay me it's my job I'm not on
the clock now if you want to if you want
to hear a joke or give like you go to a
doctor I'm a doctor oh does this look
infected it's at the same thing like
people that try to be funny offstage
usually aren't the funniest onstage I've
noticed and then the ones that are the
quietest are usually the killers long
time ago I open for Robin Williams and I
had never met the man but he whispered
the whole time I'm like oh my god this
is not gonna go good we went to dinner
he's like would you like a salad I was
like okay and then he got up on stage
and became Robin Williams and crushed
but until that moment he was the
quietest man I ever met so I think that
if we were famous we might strongly
agree okay people you know when I meet
somebody a famous comedian I'm like I
don't necessarily expect them to be
funny but I'm sure most of the world
does right like I'm sure Dave Chappelle
can't even go to the grocery store I
don't know if I want that kind of Fame
to you um why not can't go to a grocery
store
Lady Gaga tweeted this week that Fame is
prison and that stuck with me so hard I
tell offensive jokes three two one go
okay I joke about the time that I was
raped and so that can I've had people
come and tell me before that it was very
offensive to them and I am full I am not
making fun of victims at all I make fun
of just him and the female detective
that kind of botched my case so kind of
just yeah oh no it's okay you know when
I was first doing the jokes I think it
was a little too raw so I think it was
coming off as offensive but I think I
and then I just like waited and then now
that I'm coming at it four years later I
can come at it as like I feel like I've
made been able to like make it more
funny now my boyfriend died like a
couple years ago and so I have this joke
like but you guys have literally got
ghosted and people in the audience kappa
they get so mad and i'm like and then
they're like how could you and i'm like
you don't know my boyfriend because my
boyfriend would have loved that joke and
he would have been like go baby you know
so he's older man go baby
ah as a mixed-race dude i [ __ ] on white
people on cops from time to time and
while it's not it's not necessarily
attempt is to like offend white people a
cop might get offended when I say that
cops look at me and when I ask if
there's a problem they say well maybe
you know that's just how it is
I talk about white people from my own
experience working in corporate America
and I see the shifts and that you know
the way sometimes people feel
uncomfortable and I like it and then I
also talk about [ __ ] and I've my own
grandmother is offended by that but it's
fine because it's like I have one you
know a grandmother I have been
personally offended by someone else's
joke three two one go
public service announcement white comics
stop trying to say the n-word on stage I
was on bt for 10 years I was probably
the most famous white comic on there I
had a sitcom on there I got away with
saying anything I wanted on the road and
I still never used the word but it would
appear another's black and I've never
used it about her or my ex-wife or what
if that comic was trying to make a point
what's up with the me to movement I'm
like y'all were raping us that's what's
up with the goddamn [ __ ] up that's what
it's not gonna be funny and I was just I
was just out of mic and a guy was like
why are girls crying about getting raped
at least you're getting some and I'm
like oh oh yes said the wrong damn thing
and I'm so happy I don't have eggs with
me because they would be all over you
like I cannot I cannot my whole mindset
as a comic is you could say whatever you
want on stage that's what's wonderful
about comedy it's one of the last
bastions of free speech but at the same
time to go to some places that a lot of
these a lot of newer unexperienced green
comics go to ie offensive and word me
too all of that is one lazy writing and
two jumping into the deep end of a pool
when you're still have floaties on the
second step walking in if you said the
n-word on stage which I wouldn't
recommend cuz he doesn't you couldn't
but you could technically but you could
add I mean I'll be straight up with that
I'd have used the word on stage and will
become but that is because I said a
solid ten minutes building up the fact I
am a person of color I and that's a lot
different shades exactly yeah you know
we're really my daughter's just barely
darker than you yeah different shades
we're all a spectrum it is possible to
be both a great comedian and politically
correct three two one go
I have two words for you Brian Regan
Brian Regan is one of the greatest
comics out there and he does not curse
he is not offensive he sells out
theaters he has a huge following he's
maintained and advanced three decades
through since the 80s I'm not saying
he's not a great comedian but that's the
question can you be a great comedian and
be politically correct will anyone
remember him in ten years I'm not saying
you won't I will yes he has always to a
Dave Chappelle who is not PC or as
opposed to anyone else who is way more
famous how many is subjective that's
what makes it wonderful that's why there
are filthy comics and there are
Christian comics and they all have their
audience you're you're zeroing in us Oh
greatness means changing the world
greatness can mean you're not going
hungry anymore greatness can mean that
you can afford to help your family out
that's great to me
I think into comedy to be Nelson Mandela
ha ha I'm just telling jokes I'm just
trying to be funny and if you made a
crowd laugh and you made them have a
good time and you know that's what
greatness is is are you entertaining are
you making folks laugh my industry is
sexist 3 2 1 go
it was my first year doing stand-up and
I did some like comedy contest or
something like the haha cafe or whatever
and I I lost I was the only girl in it
and then the guy who was running it
comes up to me and he was like hey a
little bit of advice if you have big
tits talk about it and I was like so
taken aback I was just I was like what
excuse me and I felt disgusting I felt
objectified I have to cancel people's
trips because I will hear from a female
comic what someone said to them in a car
and to me I don't tolerate it so I just
call up that guy and say I'm replacing
you some of them are like I love it I
love I think I get advantages as being a
woman blah blah blah blah but there's
like a group of friends who believe that
who think it's a huge advantage who play
it up who do whatever you know what I
mean they think they get more bookings
because they are women the shows that
I'm booked on I see 50/50 I think and I
think it's because of the crowd I run it
you know I mean like so if you're a part
of the gay community if you're part of a
women's group and they support women in
comedy things like that you probably
will be all more diverse shows but if
you're going to the comedy store every
Monday like me and you're one of this
many women this many women of color you
know what I mean it's very difficult if
you're talking about when they're but I
think when I feel like when I feel a
push back against the game I just don't
okay I've done the Monday show at the
mmm the certain Club all right I didn't
I mean I've gone a couple of times I'm
like ooh I'm sensing a little hostility
cool doing comedy is a way for me to
work through mental health issues three
two one go
comedy is therapeutic
for me it's not therapy yes you know
this is such a weak sauce thing like my
parents divorced and recently I go on
stage to go there's something very funny
about being 25 and having your parents
divorce like all my life I wanted to
feel included or feel like somebody
could relate to me and the first time
that I did comedy like talking about
corporate America or where I'm like the
only black woman that works there and
just feeling people be like yes or I
relate to you or I've had that
experience or I know somebody who has
that made me feel like I'm not like the
only one I don't know if comedy is
enough to get me through something like
if I lost my mom or my dad I don't know
if comedy is enough to get me through
that when my parents died you know
someone made a joke about something my
dad had done and instantly I laughed and
then when my brother died some other
comics did something really funny and
shitty about him made me laugh I had a
friend that died recently and someone
wrote a top 10 list of why they were
happy he was dead and it made me laugh
and that's okay it's okay you know it
[ __ ] happens
I agree with you too that comedy is not
therapy but it's incredibly therapeutic
and I have taken I know personally leaps
in the healing process by taking my pain
and turning it into laughter I think it
alleviates the shame factor of whatever
you're feeling yeah like a fake toll
shamed just go and say yeah I'm a big
old bottom with daddy issues
all right I'm saying it and then and
then it's like aha oh great awesome
couple months ago I'm like I'm been
through a divorce and I found out like
two months after my ex and I broke up
she'd already slept with somebody and it
was it was so painful and it was so it
was humiliating and was a shot to ego
and right before I said it
right before I went to the joke I said
out loud okay here we go because I was
stepping I was literally just trusting
my my myself and the audience that
they're gonna go with me on this and
catch me when I fall and they did and
that first time that that joke worked
and got that laugh I was just like oh it
doesn't hurt as much anymore
[Applause]
[Music]